- Mmm.
- Did you poop?
(laughs)
- We are on vacation in
Puerto Vallarta, Mexico
and we decided to try
some Mexican McDonald's.
- Woo! Let's do it.
- [Man With Hat] Whoa.
- [Woman] What is this?
- It has guacamole.
- Oh.
- It really does look fancier
than the McDonald's from the US.
- It also has pico de gallo,
which I'm really excited.
- Oh.
- Mmm. Mmhmm. It's like more full.
- American McDonald's the
bread is just a sponge.
The bread definitely tastes more hardy.
- It's very cheesy.
- I would devour this.
- It's like a mix between
a burrito and a burger.
- Mmhmm. The flavors are very down home.
- All of like Mexican
flavor in one burger.
- When you can't decide between
Mexican food or American food.
- That would be a good option.
- In the sauce counter,
they also had salsa verde
and chimchurri.
- Oh!
- Spicy?
- It's not spicy, but it's
a very interesting flavor.
What really takes it to the
next level are these sauces.
Oh, is that some barbecue sauce I see?
- Yeah, it smells so
good right off the bat.
A bunch of crispy things inside too.
- Bacon, fried onions ...
- Mmm.
- It's a lot sweeter than I expected.
I'm not a huge fan of fried things,
but I would eat that burger.
- Oh, what are these?
- Fried onions?
- See this is a little too much for me.
They're getting too crazy.
- It's a little too sweet though.
I feel like the barbecue's just like ...
- Overwhelming.
- It's a lot.
- I love things that are supposed
to be savory but a little bit of sweet.
- Sweet. Yeah.
- This one was queso pie.
- So ...
What?
(laughing)
- I've never heard of this item.
- I'm intrigued. Cheese pie?
- I don't ...
- Oh!
- It's so good.
- Oh, yeah. Mmm. Mmm.
- It's really good.
- It's like soft flan.
- Do we have two of these?
- It literally is just like cheesecake
overflowing stuff in a
pie and it's delicious.
- And I love McDonald's apple pies,
but this was really really good.
Oh, I love potato wedges. Give me those.
Well we have potato wedges in
the US, but not at McDonald's.
- [Man With Hat] I'm gonna dip it in this.
- Mmm. Ah, these are incredible.
- I wish McDonald's in the US had these.
- It's hard to mess up potato wedges,
and they definitely have
not messed these up.
- Brings me back to school lunches.
- You always talk about
your school lunches
and they were clearly way better
than any of our school lunches.
- [Man With Hat] Jalapeno cheese bites.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Man With Hat] So different.
- There are so many good things.
- They kind of remind me of donut holes.
Doesn't taste like donut hole.
- Yep.
- [Man With Hat] It's like
string cheese, deep fried.
- That' really good, I love those flavors;
cheese and jalapeno.
- Kinda reminds me of nacho cheese
with jalapeno cheese mixed into it.
- I don't know if I could do the spicy
with my McDonald's.
- Really? I could.
- But the cheese is good.
Might make me farty later.
- Cajeta is my new best friend,
since I've been in Mexico.
- Do you know what it is?
- It's like caramely.
- Caramelized goat milk.
- Mmm.
- It's really refreshing,
even though it's really sweet.
- Look at how tiny it ... See,
they care about our health.
US McFlurrys are like, bah!
- I just like cajeta because
it gives you nice aftertaste.
- I feel fancier eating this.
- If you're a caramel
lover, you'll like this.
- My favorite thing was
the cheese queso pie.
- The queso pie was amazing.
- I really enjoyed the guacamole one.
Just put like a spread of
that chimichurri sauce.
- I really like the chimichurri sauce
and how well it goes with everything.
- The cheese balls and
the wedges were so good
I could eat those all day.
- Every time I have
international McDonald's,
it's always slightly
better than US McDonald's.
- We just have higher standards.
- Yeah.
- Now I'm gonna go eat more cheese balls.
- And go poop.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] And cut.